Hi there. I'm tremendously pleased to
announce the forthcoming publication of
my latest book, The Two Swords of
Christ, Five Centuries of War between
Islam and the Warrior Monks of
Christendom. Yes, it's been quite the
journey as I spent the better part of a
year researching and writing this book.
As the title indicates, it's a pure and
very raw history of the battles and
conflicts between the Christian military
orders and the forces of Islam. And as
with my other histories, it is heavily
based on primary contemporary sources,
both Christian and Muslim. Meaning,
you're going to get the real story, not
the politically correct version found in
most modern-day history books. You know,
evil, greedy Christians versus noble,
magnanimous Muslims. While there were
other lesser military orders, the book
primarily deals with the two that
spearheaded the defense of Christendom
against Islam during and well after the
Crusades, the Templars and the
Hospitalers. These knights were unique
and worthy of remembrance in that they
were and remained the chief paragonss of
muscular Christianity, an
unapologetically masculine form of the
faith that dominated much of the
premodern era. Embodying a fierce sacred
resolve. These men were neither mere
soldiers nor cloistered monks. They were
both holy warriors, men who believed
that to defend the faith was to serve
God. Indeed, their entire purpose and
reason for existence was, modern-day
Christians may be surprised to learn,
rooted in scripture, beginning with the
biblical concept of just war. They
fought not for conquest, but to protect
the innocent, uphold the sacred, and
defend Christian civilization. This
comes out repeatedly in their history
and in the book. If many modern-day
Christians believe their faith begins
and ends with being passive and
non-confrontational, turning the other
cheek, never judging and being tolerant
of everything, including unadulterated
evil. These men took into account and
tried to act on all of Christ's words.
Take his talk of swords for instance.
Christ tells his disciples that he who
has no sword, let him sell his garment
and buy one. They respond, "Lord, look,
here are two swords." Christ concludes,
"It is enough." Luke
22:36-38. Most modern-day Christians
have allegorized this verse into
absolute meaninglessness to their own
detriment. Not so for many preodern and
especially medieval Christians. That
verse's meaning was clear enough.
Christians are to fight two sorts of
evils with two sorts of swords. A
spiritual sword against spiritual
enemies and a physical sword against
physical enemies. Taken together, these
two swords were and are enough as Christ
said. Hence the title of this book, the
two swords of Christ. Not only is this
title meant to allude to the
aforementioned verse and how Christians
understood it, it has another more
symbolic meaning. Put differently, it is
precisely because the Templars and the
hospitalers believed in that in many
ways they became the two swords of
Christ.
Incidentally, even the surreal feats of
heroism performed by these men were
rooted in scripture over and over.
Verses that saying of how one man could
chase a thousand and two put 10,000 to
flight, Deuteronomy 32:30, inspired and
actuated these men to no end. Despite
all this, or perhaps precisely because
of it, the West, both secular and
Christian, has done everything either to
forget or demonize these men, especially
the Templars, who would be horrified and
utterly disgusted to see how they are
widely depicted today, or to learn that
several depraved occultist groups claim
a connection to them. It is for all
these reasons and more that I decided to
make their true story known, especially
to those Christians who insist that
faith and force are always and forever
antithetical to one another. The example
of these knights proves otherwise,
hearkening back, as it does, to a time
of moral clarity, conviction, and
courage. Okay, you can and should read
the book's description on Amazon and
wherever fine books are sold. But let me
read to you just one portion, an actual
warning that comes at the very end.
Warning. Brimming with epic battles,
stunning heroism, and self-sacrificial
martyrdom against the savage hordes of
Islam. The Two Swords of Christ, the
third installment of Ibrahim's trilogy
following Sword and Scimitar and
Defenders of the West, stands as his
fiercest and most violent narrative to
date. This warning is true and was
actually added on my recommendation. If
you've read Sword and Scimitar and/or
Defenders of the West, you're probably
already aware of the violence that
typified the clash between Islam and
Christendom. This book takes it to a
whole other level. Let's put it this
way. There's a reason the magnanimous
Saladin ordered the ritual decapitation
of hundreds of knights of the temple in
the hospital following the Battle of
Hatton. No one stood against his jihad,
shedding so much Muslim blood as did
they. So, as you can imagine, the
clashes and confrontations between these
holy warriors and the minions of Allah
were especially savage and fierce. If
you're interested, the book, which comes
out in the fall, can be pre-ordered now.
Amazon link in description. Although
it's currently being described as 352
pages, that number is actually based on
my previous two books, Sword and Simitar
and Defenders of the West, which rather
ironically, and as I just learned today,
are both exactly 352 pages. Based on
this book's word count, I expect it to
be around 4 to 500 pages. Yeah, I kind
of went overboard. It will also have
pictures. If you know of any good ones
of the Templars or Hospitalers, etc.,
Feel free to suggest them here in the
comments as I'm currently in the process
of finalizing these. Okay, there it is.
Hope you like it. I'm especially sure
all you Deos Hoot guys are going to love
it. Right up your alley. Bye.